in our culture racism is the unique sin
so worst thing you can call somebody
right now is call somebody racist
sure that's it's very bad it's an
offense against human dignity we all
acknowledge that
there are other sins and because
the left has so succeeded at eroding our
our
perception of the traditional objective
moral order
we we can't make sense of any evil in
the world other than through this lens
of white supremacy
or patriarchy racism broadly
but there are other sins tragic shooting
happened a couple of days ago at an
atlanta
area massage parlor uh this
this guy shows up the white guy
shows up and kills eight people in a
massage parlor tuesday night
he's 21 years old he's confessed to the
crimes
i think six of the
uh people were these asian masseuses
the the attacks began around 5 p.m
at the young's asian massage parlor in a
strip mall
in a rural area at near ackworth about
30 miles north of
atlanta two people died at the scene
three were transported to a hospital
where two of them also died i think more
deaths came in even after that though
i'll have to check you got the point
very very terrible thing
we are now being told that this is
because of white supremacy
because there's anti-asian hate crime
and this is part of white supremacy
if you look at the statistics not even
just from this year but for many many
years and decades
even of the demographics that commit
crimes against asian people it ain't
white supremacy let's put it that way
i'm not even particularly interested
ben will talk more about anti-asian hate
and that sort of thing on his show today
but the idea that there is an epidemic
of white people
running around killing asian people
because of their skin
is not supported by the evidence not by
a long shot
but this is what everyone jumped to they
said this because it confirms
this fictional narrative that the
cultures put forth that this guy was
motivated by
racial hatred and the cops who are
giving the they're investigating this
giving giving a press briefing on it
they're saying you know it
it doesn't seem like race is the issue
here it seems like there's another
sin at play we did interview him last
night he is currently
in our facility at the cherokee county
adult detention center
we were able to interview him with the
atlanta police department and fbi
he made indication indicators that
he has some some issues potentially
sexual addiction and um uh may have
frequent some of these places
in the past and um but as the chief
indicated is still early on we still
have a lot of uh
things to process and um what this
racially motivated
um as the chief indicated uh it's still
early
but uh the indicators right now are uh
uh it may not be uh it may be targets of
opportunity
again we're we believe that he
frequented these places in the past
and um may have been lashing out uh
and part of that is is in your media
packet as well
the working theory is a sexual addiction
issue rather than a racial profile
during our interviews we asked that
specific question
and uh and that did not appear to be the
motive
did not appear to be the motive now this
this cop is in real hot water
publicly because he was giving an
explanation of what happened he said it
was a race was it race and he said
no i think it was that that he's got
these addiction
issues and obviously these mental issues
and he had a particularly bad day
and that set him off and he went off and
committed this crime
and what trended on twitter they said he
had a bad day he had a bad day this is
covering up for white supremacy and they
just went back to the same
the same narrative so what what are they
what do they want the cop to do they
want do they want the cop to be some
emotional guy this evil terrible
monster we're gonna kill him we're gonna
no that would be
wrong for him to do that it's up to the
prosecutor to do that but for the cops
who are investigating this
gathering the facts they've got to be
neutral and of course if the situation
were reversed in any of the particulars
you would hear all sorts of excuses yes
no
uh you know we covered that story
yesterday in the tennessean
about a woman who pulled a gun on a cop
and shot him
and the article was very sympathetic to
her and more or less blamed the cop
for allowing her to shoot him write all
sorts of excuses
but i'm not interested in excuses for
any of these i'm not interested in jacob
blake's excuses
i'm not interested in this kid's excuses
i'm not interested in any any of those
sorts of things
i am however interested in
the motivations because the motivations
will tell us
quite a bit about our culture about the
crime and about perhaps how to prevent
the crime in the future
this massage parlor was i think
pretty clearly not just a massage parlor
there were three of these asian massage
parlors
on the same block just about they're all
right in the same neighborhood
something tells me there was a little
bit more than massages going on here
this is a problem that goes on
throughout the united states
and everyone knows that it's happening
and this guy apparently was frequenting
these houses of ill repute
and had this sexual addiction and this
impelled him to this horrible crime if
you
blame this on racism which is the cop
says it does not appear to be
you're not going to figure anything out
you're not going to do any any good to
help prevent these sorts of things in
the future you're not going to deal with
the root problem you're just going to
propel a leftist fantasy that that
is really divorced from reality but what
if there are more sins than sins of
racial hatred what if racial hatred
isn't even
like one of the most prominent sins in
the country
do we think that really there's this
sort of ubiquitous racial hatred do we
think that the ku klux klan is really
prominent the country
no but licentiousness sure is
that's not an excuse for someone to
commit a crime but it is an explanation
perhaps
it is a problem perhaps it is something
that we might want to deal with while
we're dealing with racial problems while
we're dealing with drug problems right
the
the opioid epidemic that's an addiction
issue
and it leads to certain crimes and
you've got to punish the crimes but you
also want to deal with the
addiction issue maybe these
this sexual insanity that's taken over
our country
where we now have the mainstreaming of
drag queen story hour
adult men transvestites twerking for
toddlers where you have 11 year old drag
kids
having dollar bills thrown at him at
bars
because he's dancing for grown men maybe
that's a problem too
maybe our antipathy toward our own
country that's spreading through
critical race theory
to use one example but through other
other means
maybe that's a problem too maybe
division
and distrust of our countrymen and the
suppression of perfectly
mainstream and conservative political
views like we're seeing at deloitte
maybe that's a problem too if you
enjoyed that break from disinformation
historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you